nearly three and a half years on the
pain is just as raw georgaras husband
david haynes was beheaded in syria in
2014 their daughter
attea knows it was bad people who killed
her daddy she was just four when he was
murdered now seven her mum has told her
those connected with his death have been
captured Joanna told Sky News about the
moment she heard her first reaction is
you want to hurt him
you want to inflict unimaginable pain to
him
I believe that's I know it's a horrible
feeling but on the other hand I'm a
human and they did something horrible to
the person I love David Haines
originally from Scotland married Ghana
in 2010 he was working for a French aid
agency in Syria close to the Turkish
border when he was kidnapped
I miss him playing with her here in
looking at two of them together it was
something special because she resembles
him so much I still got contacted by
some people he worked with and I was
contacted by people he had actually
helped
and that's the way that David keeps
living I'm sorry Joe Ghana told me she
doesn't think there will be justice for
what was done but does want a fair trial
I believe that best thing beef if
they're not going to be tried in UK
thats they will be tried in hay
International Court I hope they will go
through a fair trial and I hoped it will
get the sentences they say and that's at
least life in prison you talked about
your hopes of David's body your being
returned to you we need we need him back
I think he deserves to be buried
properly we deserve to have a place
where we can go and you know take
flowers and remember him that's the only
thing I hope it will be they will be
kept at least a bit of humanity they do
lose that little bit of humanity so they
can tell us where the bodies are so all
the families can get the remains back
what happens next
Alexander Cote and L Shafi el-sheikh
remains unclear but in a taya's bedroom
there are no thoughts of a trial
no questions over justice just a little
girl without a daddy but with a
remarkable mother delighted Sky News in
CISAC Croatia